[Music]
hello of course I'm Gil faizon and i'm
george st. geegland and this is a new
episode of too much tuna so what's up
all you tuna heads a second moment of
silence for a producer len lumpkin who
died this week from car accident
followed by an erisa he was in a car
accident he was ok a moment of silence
because lens dead we have a new crew
member taking his place
Nora Nora Nora it's a it's actually no
one oh you're Noah sometimes Gil's gonna
have dementia and you're gonna have to
shave him in the morning yeah I gotta do
it in bathtub so I can look at the hairs
float this week's episode is gonna be
extra special yeah cuz somebody's
getting pranked and they don't know
about it yet so tune in to see who's
gonna get pranked how odd it's just the
two of us sitting here on too much tuna
yeah with nobody getting pranked well as
long as we're waiting for a prank guest
why don't we have a little lunch
oh-ho what is the meaning of this this
is supposed to go in front of him
what is this not Owen now I think
there's a problem here cuz this is
supposed to be I'm actually I think this
is supposed to be over here because if
you look at this I'm not supposed to do
so in a week I'm this is not for me
either this is not supposed to know I'm
not I'm supposed to give this to him you
got too much tuna what do you got a
potato bun there's something under it
I'm not even looking I don't even care
the tables have turned friend there's a
whole magnet tuna fish right Freddie
yeah look what's happened here uh-oh
it's it's too much it's too much tuna
it's I've been pranked it's too much
tuna you're born as schmuck and you're -
buck welcome to hell idiot
yes
you